par ses mots et ses mélodies il s'est
réveillé nos émotions
frédéric joron surprend toujours par son
indémodable talent cette année il fête
ses 40 ans de carrière
incontournable pour nous de le retrouver
ici à sainte suzanne
non
nana
un jour
la maison
mais y en a
[Musique]
c'est comme samuel
merci frédéric joron accueil à nous pour
cause des 40 ans de carrière conseil
représente pour cet anniversaire la 40
ans c'est vrai que là
chemin des ja et la eu des hauts et des
bas de bons moments là lui aussi les
moments moins agréable mais bon on va
dire qu'il fait partie de la vie koussa
la marque à ou quand on regarde derrière
et qu'on regarde le chemin parcouru nous
disait tout haut ce que les gens y
pensent tout bas et c'était l'époque où
six cas quand l'été la ravanne dernier
droit au master mouvement culturel de
bastia tout ça et c'était une époque où
les vins au top de mon année la grande
envie de chanter elle avait envie de
faire quelque chose et tous les samedis
m'avait avec à bavay spectacle et ça
avait été gagnée je suis à la pousse à
eau a commencé à créer le groupe
ousanousava lors d'un déménagement donc
nous tient en train de jeter un esclave
et a ajouté on va parler chez tri et la
lave est un endroit il ya peu le sport
et la vie d'emma il faut il dans la
voirie trapio watts gâtés et ses amants
j'ai maté jamais vu une affaire concerne
montée
lors son instituteur qui allait après
noisy garçons directeur il savait
comment s'écrit montceau donc le premier
morceau est mal écrit en créole
il ya peu le petit paris et puis ben
de fil en aiguille la compose des
morceaux dans mon école monte et monte
ça va est ce que tu es connu ou sauter
ça va est ce que la presse est maman
nous a mis beaucoup ça va ça ne me
connaissez pas en fait le nom change ça
va c'est maintenant mallet trouvé ce nom
là c'était questions et les réponses en
même temps ousanousava quel côté me
savard fils théo boston ça va comme ça
donc c'est elle c'est une affirmation
qui le dit et fait quand même des tas
[Musique]
non
on sait les couleurs
hamidi qui nous réunissent arrivait
[Musique]
suit derrière
et dans mais c'était l'école c'est
l'école de l'amour l'école apprendre et
à moitié cochon comment il est passé
balayés comme en irak pour moi c'était
l'abri si le terrain en fait c'était de
donner sans rien attendre en retour
mais c'est quoi qui inspira aujourd'hui
quand ricky vos morceaux le thème le
thème principal c'est surtout que nous
parle beaucoup d'amour nous parle
beaucoup de la culture nous parle
beaucoup de la société marié très social
donc
canafe touchant moins de prêts médailles
par rapport à mai soit mycoses et des
fois on m'a dit nicolas michaud
j'sais pas
ne plaît pas
[Musique]
m
l homme
[Musique]
pour moi
amy ikaruga aux portes aujourd'hui sur
la musique polonaise
nos grands parents avaient des valeurs
des outils transmettez et qui
transmettait au niveau de la musique
aujourd'hui me direz il faudrait
retrouver un petit peu retourné un petit
peu à la sauce mouais c'est vrai que je
partirai du principe que la musique
évolue mais peut-être que c'est moi rien
y changer ce que voit ce que la vie
avant la source la souche que la vie
avance cette culture les racines mais il
faut il faut arroser il faut donner
on espère que nous pourra écouter
longtemps la souche frédéric joron merci
beaucoup merci merci aux autres mais
aussi l union pour venir